a grand jury declines to indict police
officers in the death of black man
daniel prude
the first black bachelor complains about
systemic racism and democrats struggle
with joe biden putting kids in cages i'm
ben shapiro this is the venture bureau
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands my listeners have already
secured their internet join them at
expressvpn.com
slash ben we're gonna get to all the
news in just one moment a lot of
cultural news out
today so we'll get to all of that first
let me remind you you're spending way
too much on that telephone bill and
there is no reason for you to spend that
much money on your cell phone bill you
could
be like one of my thousands of listeners
and join puretalk
usa really over a thousand of you have
made the switch from your overpriced
wireless carrier to pure talk over the
past couple of months so what are the
rest of you waiting for if you're with
att verizon or t-mobile your family
could save over 800
a year just by switching to puretalk you
get the same great coverage because they
use the exact same towers as one of the
big carriers
you can even keep your phone and your
number but you're gonna save a fortune
by the way puretalk is the top-rated
wireless company by consumer affairs
with the absolute best
customer service team based right here
in america sound good
it gets better right now get unlimited
talk text and six gigs of data for just
30 bucks a month
and if you go over on data they're not
going to charge you for it so exactly
what are you waiting for at this point
grab your mobile phone dial pound 250
say my name ben shapiro when you do you
say 50
off your first month style pound 250 say
keyword ben
shapiro pure talk usa is simply smarter
wireless go check them out right now
dial pound 250 say ben shapiro and get
started on switching over and saving
yourself a bundle
in the process okay so the news of the
day
is that rochester officers are not going
to be charged in the death of daniel
prude
so you may remember the daniel pruitt
case it was another one of these cases
where the tape
looks really unpleasant but the reality
is that the officers are
almost certainly not responsible for the
death of daniel prude it created riots
during the black lives matter
situation during the summer in rochester
particularly
this came out kind of late in the summer
because originally
the daniel pruitt died in march but then
the tape didn't come out until a couple
of months later it became just another
one of the names that is
listed in the litany of people who are
supposedly murdered by the police
many of those names don't belong on that
list right jacob blake was put on that
list he's not dead but
he was put on the list he was
responsible for the riots in kenosha it
turned out that he had
a knife in his hand when he was refusing
to obey the
orders of officers it turns out not all
of these cases are exactly
the same and daniel prude falls into the
category of a case
where it is absolutely unclear that the
officers killed him in fact the evidence
tends to show
the opposite according to the new york
times on a snowy night last march daniel
proved sprinted shirtless out of his
brother's home in rochester new york
seemingly in the grip of a psychotic
episode distraught his brother called
police for help
instead the officers handcuffed mr prude
placed a mesh hood over his head and
pressed him into the pavement until he
lost consciousness
okay now that is a wild exaggeration of
the actual chain of events
so we actually have the tape right the
police tape came out of what happened
here
and daniel prude is walking down the
street
in the middle of rochester it is snowing
outside and he is completely
nude at the time and he starts shouting
at the officers give me your gun
and so they restrain him and then he
starts trying to spit at them and he
says
that he is coveted positive remember
this is early on in the pandemic this is
like two weeks
into the shutdown of the pandemic and so
they do what
officers are trained to do they put a
mesh hood on him it is breathable
did not put him in a burlap sack they
didn't choke him to death
okay and then it appears that he died of
excited delirium and because it turns
out that he was probably extremely high
on pcp
that is what the autopsy showed again he
was walking naked down the street in
rochester so this obviously was not
somebody
who was in a decent mental or physical
condition when the officers first
encountered him here's a little bit of
what that tape looked like
get on the ground man get on the ground
put your hands behind your back
behind your back don't move don't move
chill out man don't move i mean it god
bless y'all man
get them away from me and jesus christ i
pray
amen give me that gun
you hear him say give me that gun and
then they and then they put him and they
hold him down because he is not staying
down right
that mesh hood is breathable and then at
a certain point
he says that he can't breathe which is
true because
he can't breathe he's suffering from
excited delirium
the autopsy said that he was
experiencing excited delirium which is a
condition that often follows heavy drug
use
similar autopsy report was made about
for example george floyd in minneapolis
the autopsy tends to show that he did
not die as a direct result of the
officer's
pressure in that particular case that he
was high on fentanyl at the time
something similar happened here with
daniel prude according to the best
available scientific reports
according to the new york times miss
james leticia james
who is the who is the attorney general
of the state of new york she said she
was extremely disappointed with the
grand jury which is always a good move
it's always a good move when you have
officers of the law saying they are
disappointed with the workings of the
law
in any case on tuesday the new york
attorney general leticia james announced
none of the officers who arrested prude
would face charges in connection with
his death a grand jury convened by james
to investigate the case declined to
charge any of the seven officers on the
scene that night with a crime
miss james said the criminal justice
system has demonstrated an unwillingness
to hold law enforcement
enforcement officers accountable in the
unjustified killing of african americans
what binds these cases is the tragic
loss of life in circumstances
in which the death could have been
avoided if she has a way that people can
escape
dying from excited delirium i would love
to hear it seriously
in an unusual move a monroe county court
judge karen bailey turner on tuesday
evening granted the attorney general's
request to release minutes
related to the grand jury's
investigation records that are generally
protected under seal
ms james said the public deserves to
know what transpires behind closed doors
which of course
defeats the purpose of a blind jury
system the date to make the documents
public has not been set
the federal doj says they might open a
civil rights investigation into the
officers
they've tried this before under barack
obama usually it fails you'll remember
that it was eric holder's doj
that refused to incite george zimmerman
in the death of trayvon martin
for example on tuesday evening a crowd
of about 150 people marched through the
city denouncing the grand jury decision
in the system
that made it possible the system that
made it possible you mean like
trial by by jury and grand jury process
and due process of law that that system
according to the new york times after
body camera video of mr prude's death
became public in the fall
his name now joined a now familiar list
of black people killed during
interactions with police including
george floyd whose death in minneapolis
led to months of demonstrations
nationwide particularly unsettling in
the case of mr images of him
in a hood reminiscent of the ones used
in lynching of black people that is not
what happened
these police officers did not arrive on
scene and decide you know what let's
lynch this guy
he started spitting at them yelling at
them and he was coveted positive at that
point
again we were two weeks into the
pandemic at this point so they put a
spit hood on him
which is a mesh hood that you can
breathe through
the rochester police locust club which
is the union that represents the city's
700 law enforcement officers declined to
comment on the grand jury's decision
naturally leticia james suggested that
there had to be sweeping reforms in how
the police interact with
and are trained to deal with people in
emotional distress
buried in this article from the new york
times are the actual circumstances here
mr prude 41 lived in chicago but had had
been visiting his brother in rochester
friends said that before his death mr
prude had begun to rely more heavily on
the drug pcp
this is one of the more dangerous drugs
known to man known as angel dust it can
cause erratic behavior he began to use
drugs they said to cope with the 2018
death by suicide of his nephew with whom
he had lived
the day before the episode his brother
joe had him hospitalized at strong
memorial hospital for a psychiatric
evaluation but he was sent home hours
later so if you're going to put blame
anywhere
it ought to be with the psychiatric
hospital that released this guy because
by the next night he was out on the
street wandering around naked in the
snow
and shouting at police officers that he
wanted their gun and that he had covered
while trying to spit at them
just hours after returning from the
hospital on march 23rd mr pruitt
suddenly burst from his brother's home
and ran into the night
fearful for his safety his brother
called 9-1-1
and people obviously fear the police so
much that they call 9-1-1 when they have
a problem
worried prude might inadvertently harm
himself or run across nearby train
tracks
police who answered the call found prude
naked and reported he had told at least
one passerby he had covered
when they apprehended him he began
spitting and the officers responded by
pulling the measured over his head
when he tried to rise the officer's
force mister proved face down on the
ground one of them pushed his head to
the pavement police body camera footage
showed
the police held proof down for two
minutes he had to be resuscitated he
died at the hospital
a week later okay now again the reality
of the autopsy is that he
likely died of his drug intake and
excited delirium which is a condition
that often follows heavy drug use one of
the symptoms of excited delirium is that
you feel overheated which might be one
of the reasons why he shed all of his
clothes in the middle of the night in
rochester
when it was freezing outside and snowing
a deputy police chief in rochester wrote
in a june 4th email to his supervisor
saying we certainly do not want people
to misinterpret the officer's actions
and conflate this incident with any
recent killings of unarmed black men by
law enforcement nationally that would
simply be a false narrative and could
create animosity and potentially violent
blowback in the community
as a result the new york times
interpreted that letter as an attempted
cover-up
as opposed to the police saying you guys
are going to misinterpret the tape and
then everybody going and misinterpreting
the tape
late last year the offices the city's
office of public integrity
apparently concluded no wrongdoing had
been committed by any city employee
ms james suggested daniel prude was in
the throes of a mental health crisis
what he needed was compassion care and
helped from trained professionals
tragically he received none of those
things he literally was at the hospital
the day before and they discharged him
so people are using this as yet another
example of
black men being brutally mistreated by
the police this is a bad example
you can find examples of black men being
brutally mistreated by police
you can find examples of white men being
brutally mistreated by the police
those situations do happen this happens
to be a particularly poor example but it
leads all the news
because the news people do not care your
journalistic experts
do not care about the particular
circumstances of every individual case
they don't care about due process they
don't care about what the actual
evidence shows they don't care about
autopsy reports they have a narrative
and they never must
the narrative must be promoted and the
narrative has an effect
i have some pull statistics that are
absolutely stunning that i'm going to
show you in
just one second first let us talk about
the fact a lot is happening at your
front door these days you got a lot of
people dropping off packages you have
people maybe working on your house you
need to know what is happening on your
property
at all times and this is why you need
ring devices
it is the perfect time to upgrade your
doorstep with a ring of video doorbell
with ring
you can see and speak to whomever is at
the door from anywhere right on your
phone so you're never going to miss a
visitor
whether it's your neighbor your dinner
or your groceries and you can keep those
packages and delivery safe
with motion detection you'll get
notified even if they don't ring the
doorbell if someone stops by or
something is going on ring
we'll let you know i have ring devices
on my house because
not only are there a lot of people who
are constantly coming in and out of the
house but also
i have three kids it's very difficult to
keep an eye on all three kids when i
have butt two eyes and they only go in
the same direction so that means that i
need more eyes on my kids these cameras
in my house allow me to do that
makes me feel safer and makes my wife
feel safer when we moved one of my
wife's first demands is that we put ring
devices on the house
and thus we did so right now get a
special offer on the ring welcome kid at
ring.com
bennett comes with ring video doorbell 3
and chime pro it's the perfect way to
upgrade your front door and start your
ring experience
go to ring.com that is ring.com
ben okay so the impact of the coverage
of the media
in cases like daniel pruitt's the
suggestion that this is a grave
miscarriage of justice by letitia james
this has an impact on
how people think about racism in the
united states
so there's a poll done by skeptic
magazine and they surveyed people
of various political persuasions on a
simple question how many black men
in america unarmed were killed by police
in 2019
right that is a simple objective
question how many people how many black
men who are unarmed were killed by the
police
in 2019 now the actual statistic
so you know ranges based on the
washington post there are other reports
that suggest higher
it's some at a maximum it is 27 at a
maximum it is 27.
and you would know that if you listen to
shows like this one because we actually
focus in on the data we actually talk
about the fact that in a country with 40
million black americans
black americans are not a genocidal
existential risk from law enforcement
it's just a lie it is not true
but folks on the left like to promulgate
that narrative in fact that narrative is
so unbelievably popular that you had
literally 10 to 25 million people in the
streets repeating the lie
that america's police are systemically
racist over the summer
and he had some of those people going
and burning down the local
so here is how americans how many
americans believe
black men were killed by the police
unarmed in 2019
and there's a serious differential in
terms of political persuasion here
so if you are very conservative you know
not very many black men are killed
unarmed by the police in fact 46 percent
of very conservative people knew that
the answer is about 10.
another 34 of very conservative
americans said that the answer was about
100.
okay so that's at least somewhat close
right i mean at least that's ballpark
a grand total of approximately
20 percent of very conservative people
overall thought that over a thousand
black men were killed unarmed in 2019 by
the cops
now let's look at the very liberal crowd
the very liberal crowd
15.71 of very liberal americans believed
that about 10
black men were killed unarmed by the
cops in 2019
fully i'm not joking fully
31 thought that about 1 000
unarmed black men were killed by the
cops in 2019 another 14.29
thought that about 10 000 unarmed black
men were killed by the police in 2019
and 7.86 percent thought more than 10
000 were killed
by the cops in 2019 which is utterly
crazy
so when you add those three numbers
together what you end up with
is a majority a majority of very liberal
people believe
that over 1 000 black men were killed
unarmed by the cops in 2019
the actual answer at a maximum is 27.
so they are only off by like two orders
of magnitude
okay there's a reason for that and the
reason for that is the media coverage
and by the way here's the big problem
this holds true
for normal liberal people not just
variable people normal liberal people
normal liberal people believe that
many many more unarmed black men were
killed than actually were killed
26.67 percent of normal liberal people
believe a thousand black men a year are
killed
unarmed by the cops another 12
think that at least 10 000 people
were killed by the cops unarmed black
every single year
now once you get to people who are
moderate and who don't believe the
narrative quite as much
you still end up with a huge percentage
of americans who believe that the number
is way higher than it is
right fully 41 of moderates believe that
about 100 people were killed a year by
the cops
unarmed and black and 16 still believe
that about a thousand were killed what
you see
is that as these polls get more
conservative they get more accurate
right the more conservative these folks
are the more accurate they are in fact
there's only one exception to this rule
and that is actually between very
conservative and conservative people
if you're just conservative and not very
conservative you're actually more
accurate on this question
about 86 of just conservative people
understood that the answer was below
100.
okay so here is the problem the
narrative has purchased
and the narrative is a lie black men are
not being routinely
gunned down by cops unarmed every year
and this holds true throughout our
society
every time you hear about systemic
racism you should be asking for the data
what is the evidence
that a disparity is in fact
discrimination but people don't bother
people do not bother to actually answer
that question
okay so there is a there is a another
poll
statistic from skeptic okay and the
question was in 2019
what percentage of people killed by
police total were black the actual
answer is about 30 percent
actually sorry it's about 25 about one
quarter of all people killed by the cops
in 2019 or black the vast majority of
those people as we've just explored
we're armed or threatening the cops in
some way okay
once again once again
the very liberal people get this one
completely wrong they believe
that 60 of all people killed by the cops
in 2019 were black
60 6 in 10 people killed by the cops
were black according to very liberal
people according to liberal people
56 percent of people who were killed by
the cops in 2019 were black
total okay again that is off by at least
a factor of two
moderates 46 percent they believe that
of people who were killed by the cops
were black in 2019.
conservatives were the closest once
again people who just consider
themselves conservative
were the closest on this score they say
that 37.8 percent of people killed by
the cops were black again the real
number
is 25 so every single subgroup in
american life thought the number was
higher than it was
very conservative people thought 44.5 of
people killed by the cops were black
okay so here's the reality even among
conservatives the narrative has
purchased
because when you keep hearing over and
over and over that black men are being
gunned down and when the only stories
that you hear
are black men being shot by the police
as opposed to white people being shot by
the police or hispanic people being shot
by the police
well then you end up with a narrative
and the narrative often times is
extraordinarily false
and here's the thing we live in a
society where it's not enough
that you hear the narrative you must
parrot the narrative
and if you don't parrot the narrative
you'll be called out for being unwoke
you'll be called out for not being one
of the people who is
sophisticated one of the people who
doesn't see you you'll be it'll be
suggested that you're naive you don't
see through the system
in fact you are a you are a pillar of
the system
you are a person who makes this evil
system possible unless you
repeat a false narrative and this has
infused every aspect of our culture
and so you see it every single day
corporations around america
you see it in entertainment in a second
we're gonna get to a bizarre cultural
conversation i can't believe i'm gonna
talk about the bachelor but it's
actually kind of culturally indicative
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about your sleep
quality so
as you may know my kids been waking me
up all hours of the night well when i
finally lie down and i put my head on my
pillow i need
the world's best pillow and this is why
i have my pillow my pillow products
don't go flat you can wash and dry them
as many times as you want
they maintain their shape best of all
they're made right here in the united
states
if you don't have a my pillow or you
know somebody who doesn't now is the
time to get one because for a limited
time my pillow is offering their premium
my pillows for their lowest price ever
you can get a queen size premium my
pillow regularly 69.98
for only 29.98 that is 40 bucks and
savings kings
are only five bucks more folks now is
the time to buy not only
are you getting the lowest price ever
but they're the best guests ever it's
29.98 for a queen size premium my pillow
buy now they'll extend that 60-day
money-back guarantee to march 1st 2021.
head on over to mypillow.com click on
that radio listener square there you
will find not only this incredible offer
but also deep discounts on all my pillow
products including the giza dream bed
sheets
the my pillow mattress topper and my
pillow towel sets or call 800
651 1148 and use promo code daily wear
this makes a great gift by the way
go check them out right now head on over
to mypillow.com click on that radio
listener's square and let them know that
we sent you by using promo code
daily wire call 800-651-111-48 use that
promo code daily wire
as well okay so meanwhile
you know my friend andrew breitbart used
to say that culture is upstream of
politics and it is true
when you hear from all of your cultural
sources all of them that america is
systemically racist and evil
you start to believe it and when you see
that people are called out and cudgelled
into line if they don't repeat that
narrative you start to say to yourself
well maybe i should do that too
right maybe i need to say all this woke
stuff because if i don't say that woke
stuff i'll get fired from my job at
woca cola or maybe i will be tossed out
by my local university or maybe all of
my friends will unfriend me on facebook
okay this is infused even some of our
most apolitical
dumb cultural institutions so i say dumb
because i will
freely admit to you i am not a a watcher
of the bachelor i think the premise of
the show is idiotic
frankly the notion that you have one
person who's dating 20 people at once i
think it's kind of perverse
the fact that people think this is
romantic is absolutely beyond me it must
be part of the lizard brain
that sees any sort of romantic gesture
as romantic even if it's done
in the context of a highly and slickly
produced
program in which a dude is dating 20
chicks at once
okay but in any case being a non-fan of
the bachelor i think this gives me in
some ways more credibility to talk about
the stupidity
of what is now going on at the bachelor
okay the bachelor has been in a
political show that men have not wanted
to watch for 25 years
it's the kind of show where your wife
turns it on and watches it and is
enthralled and you
sit there and you just wish that you
could turn the channel to football
but it is one of the key institutional
cultural touchstones of our society
clearly right i mean it's been around
for forever
right it's an it's a cultural
institution in america it's been one of
the highest rated shows on tv
since 2002. it has been
around it has been around more than half
my life on tv
okay so now the bachelor is imploding
and it's imploding
because there is a contestant named
rachel connell and rachel corconell
several years ago went to a antebellum
themed
plantation party when she was in college
this involved basically dressing up like
scarlett o'hara at a plantation
and this was considered wildly uncouth
and racist and covered by the internet
sleuths
those great people doing amazing things
like suggesting that people are racist
because they dressed up as scarlett
o'hara
at a an antebellum themed party
in the south as though this was sort of
some sort of referendum on slavery that
probably racial corconel was totally
cool with slavery because of this
probably that was that is the most
obvious takeaway right i mean that's the
most obvious takeaway okay so
when that first came out the contestants
on the bachelor of the season is a black
man his name is matt james
and matt james originally
came out on february 3rd and reacted
by asking for some grace for her matt
james here's what matt james
said here's a direct quote i have not
spoken to anybody since the show ended
but i would say that you have to be
really careful about what you are doing
on social media
rumors are dark and they're nasty and
they can ruin people's lives so i would
give people the benefit of the doubt
and hopefully she will have her time to
speak on that
now spoiler alert i mean it's well all
over the noise but here's the news but
here's your spoiler alert if you're one
of the
number of of people who for some odd
reason loved the show
matt did end up with rachel in the show
right he picked her
right he ended up with her and that was
matt james the black contestant on the
bachelor saying we should show her some
grace
the social media judge jury they should
they really should not be doing what
they're doing
people on social media decided to check
into like her parents voting record
they decided that she had to be canceled
because she went to this antebellum
themed party and boy isn't it fun
to go get this lady let's just go right
after this lady because she disagrees
politically with us or her parents
disagree politically with us
and also she went to an ill-advised
themed party in 2018
when she was in college okay so that's
the setup
the setup is that she does something
that is
somewhat questionable in in the modern
context but certainly not questionable
as
even five to ten years ago and i mean
at that point it would have been
considered kind of crazy to cancel
somebody over something like this now
you cancel somebody over
literally saying the n word to denounce
the n word so everything is cancellable
but it was so crazy that even matt james
the black bachelor was like uh yeah guys
you need to give her some space okay
that is the setup that is the setup
fast forward about three weeks
right because that was february 3rd
february 3rd the bachelor contestant
matt james comes out and defends her
and then a couple days later chris
harrison who's the host of the bachelor
he comes out and says basically the
exact same thing as matt ames right
just a couple days later he comes out he
does an interview and he says maybe we
should show her some grace
social media is not judged during an
executioner you're ruining somebody's
life maybe you ought to take into
account the fact that she was young and
stupid when you're young and stupid or
young and stupid
maybe she can explain herself maybe
she'll apologize
okay and then chris harrison got hit
with the with the
anvil of wokism it was just dropped on
his head from the third story
and so he ended up being suspended from
his own show
for the great crime of suggesting that a
young woman ought to be given grace
saying the exact same thing in nearly
the exact same words that matt james
said okay the reason that this all
started
is because there's a former bachelor
contestant named rachel lindsay okay so
rachel lindsay
went after chris harrison and said it
was racist of him he didn't understand
she said when she was not cutting ads
for cadillac in the middle of the black
lives matter protest
she said that it was very very important
that chris harrison understood the
context of his own
racist sentiment and the producers of
the bachelor wanting to avoid
controversy then removed chris harrison
from the final episodes of the bachelor
which is kind of incredible
actually okay fast forward about three
weeks
now matt james who by the way picked
rachel connell
again he picked her after defending her
at the beginning of february
now he has issued a full-scale statement
not only
denouncing rachel kirk connell and
throwing her under the bus i mean this
guy's
what a douchebag honestly seriously he
was defending her three weeks ago what
changed in three weeks other than he
didn't like the media blowback
so he took a girl who was dating him
right and then he just tossed her under
the bus and the show
that made him a star and a relevant
person in american life
the first black bachelor a show so
apparently racist
that you had women of all different
racial makeups
dating the main character who's black so
obviously this is a deeply racist
terrible show now matt james has flipped
on a dime
and now he says the show is racist chris
harrison is racist and he
is woke which makes this guy not only a
douchebag but a coward
so matt james put out a statement and
says the past few weeks have been some
of the most challenging in my life
and while there are several episodes
left of the season it is important that
i take the time to address the troubling
information that has come to light since
we wrapped filming
including the incredibly disappointing
photos of rachel corconell and the
interview between
rachel lindsay and chris harrison wow
so he went from let's give her some
grace and treat people like human beings
too i'm incredibly disappointed in
everyone around me and it's definitely
not my fault and please leave me alone
and maybe i should be on the cover of a
magazine
talking about racial problems in america
matt james writes the reality is that
i'm learning about these situations in
real time
oh really because uh back on february 30
you knew about them so uh
if by in real time you knew that the
photos were out at the beginning of
february and you defended her
and now you're too much of a coward to
stand by it there's that
he said it's been devastating and
heartbreaking to put it bluntly chris's
failure
to receive and understand the emotional
labor that my friend rachel lindsay was
taking on by graciously and patiently
explaining the racist history of the
antebellum south a painful history that
every american should understand
intimately was troubling and painful to
watch okay that's just put that i'm
sorry that's ridiculous
ridiculous the labor and pain the
emotional labor rachel lindsay was
taking on
again this is a lady who in the middle
of the black lives matter protest she's
like you know how i
fight for black lives matter i put on
podcasts talking about
about black history in my beautiful
cadillac xt6
i'm not kidding that's an actual
instagram post she put up
okay it is a po it is a post in which
she touts black lives matter and she
says
she can listen to podcasts about black
history on her beautiful
bose sound system in her cadillac xt
xt6 emotional labor my ass
rachel lindsay couldn't be reveling in
this anymore if you paid her and they
are paying her
emotional labor come on yeah she seemed
i mean it must be real emotional labor
having to explain to people that they
should be canceled
not because they're actively racist or
believe in the inferiority of black
people but that they should be canceled
because they suggest grace for a person
who went to a party
that was ignorant and and that should be
that's cancelable and not only that the
person who says maybe we should give
that person grace
give them a chance to explain themselves
and apologize to even explain to that
person
to even explain to that person is
emotional labor
you cannot even explain to chris
harrison that is an emotion it's an act
of emotional labor
emotional labor honest to god
pay me for that kind of emotional labor
give me a cadillac sponsorship for that
kind of emotional labor
emotional labor as black people and
allies immediately knew and understood
it was a clear reflection of a much
larger issue
that the bachelor franchise has fallen
short on addressing adequately for years
again
matt james is the first black bachelor
the first one okay and rachel lindsay
was a contestant on the bachelor she's
very famous now
this is yes that that is nailed it right
matt you nailed it
it turns out that it has dawned on you
now that you are a participant in the
most racist franchise in american
history obviously the bachelor
is like birth of a nation except with
dating and a black lead
who's the hero and him dating a bunch of
uh
lindsay by the way was the first black
bachelorette forgive me for my ignorance
on matters concerning the bachelor one
of the dumbest shows of all time
matt james continues this moment has
sparked critical conversations and
reporting no it has not
it has sparked stupid conversations and
bad reporting raised important questions
no it has not the only important
question is
why is it that you are running away from
your own
from your own willingness to grant
people the benefit of the doubt
people you are dating by the way and
then the minute that there's some
blowback you throw her under the bus
and you suggest that you're a hero for
doing so and resulted in inspiring
displays of solidarity from the bachelor
nation
it has also pushed me to reevaluate and
process what my experience on the
bachelor represents
oh so now he's going to reevaluate right
we're going to go back and we're going
to re-process
we're really going to think hard about
what a rough life he had dating 20 women
at once
on national television and being paid
for the privilege
it has pushed me to reevaluate and
process what my experience on the
bachelor represents not just for me
but of all the contestants of color he's
a representative of all black americans
black america do you understand this guy
represents you apparently according to
him
especially the black contestants of this
season and seasons past and for you
the viewers at home i will continue to
process this experience and you will
hear more from me
in the end my greatest prayer is that
this is an inflection point that results
in real and
institutional change for the better i'm
sorry this is the stupidest crap i've
ever heard
it does not make the culture better it
makes the culture significantly worse if
you look
at this season of the bachelor as a
victory for american racial tolerance
you're missing you're missing it because
what it was
was a victory for conciliation and then
the woke came
and decided to completely destroy
everything and the
bachelor again he started it man he
started it he defended kurt connell
he defended her at the beginning of
february and within three weeks he has
flipped
he's not only inciting kurt connell as a
racist he's indicting chris harrison as
a racist and the entire bachelor
franchise is a racist
as racist he's doing all of that within
three weeks because rachel lindsay said
you are you are obviously a sellout
essentially right i mean that that must
have been the case that she was making
publicly
or at least he felt that way pretty
incredible stuff there
pretty incredible stuff because the show
ain't racist you know what the proof is
that the show ain't racist
the show there is no good evidence that
rachel connell is a racist
not only did she post a groveling
apology
for the antebellum stuff she's put out a
bunch of statements
since that rachel lindsay has found
insufficient and rachel lindsay as the
pope
of wokeness gets to determine whether or
not you are
sufficiently whether you're sufficiently
deferential to woke principles
and she'll do so while standing in front
of a cadillac xts by the way it's a xd6
it's impressive stuff i will admit cause
nothing says america is racist quite
like getting to rip america as racist
the show that you start in as
racist the host of that show as racist
other contestants on that show as racist
and the entire system of the united
states is racist while standing in front
of a beautiful cadillac
xt6 with a bose sound system
clearly this is an awful awful country
for people like rachel lindsay clearly
she has suffered greatly in her life
clearly matt james has suffered the
emotional labor oh
the emotional labor oh the emo emotional
labor my ass
seriously ridiculous ridiculous stuff
but don't worry we're making the country
less racist one cancellation at a time
it's all very exciting stuff i'm excited
to report to you
that the latest in in making the country
less racist
is that harry shearer a white actor will
no longer voice the black character dr
hibbert
on the simpsons now if it ever occurred
to you like who voiced that character
then congratulations to the dozen of you
like seriously uh who sits around going
the voice-over artist what color are
they
hm i guarantee you one thing the
simpsons is super racist because virtual
a lot of the characters on the simpsons
are yellow many of those characters are
yellow
and i guarantee you that not a single
person who's ever voiced one of those
characters has that same color because
that color doesn't exist on humans in
real life
it's very it's very upsetting i mean
honestly unless we have people who voice
over these characters who have all the
characteristics of the characters on
cartoons
i think that we we absolutely should not
be able to do these things anymore
unless you as a human being if you are
hit in the face of the frying pan and
your face
takes on the shape of a frying pan i do
not think you should be able to voice a
cartoon character
who when hit in the face with a frying
pan has their face taken on the shape
of a frying pan all characteristics must
be shared
it was clearly a sign of deep american
racism that a white actor was
voicing over a black character on a
cartoon
racism solved gang shurer has voiced
springfield's most skilled doctor in
contrast to hank's area's incompetent
doctor nick
since 1990 he also voices ned flanders
and principal skinner among
other characters he will continue
voicing the other roles
he joins this area who last year
announced he'd be no longer voicing the
indian character apu
in part after a 2017 documentary the
problem with apu brought attention to
the subject
yes this is great this also follows
family guy actor mike henry who is white
announcing
in the aftermath of the george floyd
incident that he would not be
voicing the black character cleveland
anymore
and that solved racism guys is amazing i
mean
you know you know how much less racist
american society got since mike henry
who is white announced he would not be
voicing cleveland anymore
every day we draw closer we draw closer
to utopia it's it's really really
exciting stuff i'm just glad that i
could be alive when we decided that we
were going to
basically purge everybody who doesn't
agree with the most woke among us
and then cuddle everybody else into
imitating that viewpoint i'm just i'm
grateful to be living in such a virtuous
time
truly because we know that we're on the
verge of eliminating racism by calling
every single person in the united states
racist
every single show in the united states
racist determining that
everybody should be canceled for their
past views except the people who get to
join the mob and if you join the mob
then you're basically okay
and not only that you get to be a leader
in the movement and we celebrate you
and we talk about how you're right don't
you feel
the joy and hope you're wait you're
saying that
this is all depressing and it makes you
despairing that we that we are living
in a free and tolerant country no don't
you understand
the revolution is afoot and it's a
wonderful revolution in which we will
promulgate false narratives
and in which we'll push those false
narratives with every every piece of
institutional power at our disposal and
we will run right over you if you
disagree
isn't that great it's so much fun okay
in just a minute we're going to get to
the unfortunate fact that apparently joe
biden is putting kids in cages
it's just like i mean aoc told me that
when trump did it was like a
concentration camp so
i don't know that lady knows everything
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first
let us talk about improving your
business in the face of change
local businesses are using podium to
grow stronger than ever
podium gives your business the messaging
tools to turn your website into a
thriving storefront
you can connect with leads customers and
teammates as easily as text messaging
and when you close the deal podium even
makes it easy to get paid
contact free over text podium is the
ultimate messaging platform for local
businesses with podium reviews you can
easily text customers to leave an online
review improving search rankings
podium web chat will let website
visitors text with your team right
from your homepage meet with customers
from anywhere with podium video chat get
paid fast
over text with podium payments podium
inbox brings it all together keep leads
warm respond to feedback all in one
place
don't take my word for it rpm alamo
increased business by 20
tony is the owner of rpm alamo he said
we've generated more revenue
decreased vacancy rates and pulled in
more leads than we could have in
multiple years this is priceless
find out how podium can help your
business reach more customers get
started free today at podium.com
shapiro again that is podium.com shapiro
podium is making your business more
efficient it's making it better if
you've not
engaged in texting it definitely is
going to help your business go to
podium.com
shapiro and get that process started
right now get started free at podium.com
shapiro okay we'll get to more on all
the news in just one second first
it is that time of the month when i get
to sit down with some of my favorite
people
in the world and michael knowles for an
episode of backstage that is right join
me
and jeremy boring and matt walsh and
andrew clavin and yes the explorable
michael mills tonight
at 7pm eastern as we roundtable about
current events and big picture picture
issues
like perhaps cancel culture or so join
us
at dailywire.com or on the daily wire
youtube to watch again
that is 7 p.m eastern 6 p.m central now
before going any further
i got to tell you about a new show that
we are bringing out hosted by moa i told
you there's going to be lots of new
content this year it's daily wire for
our members and there is
we have a simple highly effective rule
for making a good argument
don't build good arguments on false
facts this is the
first and most important rule when it
comes to developing a legitimate
argument but
the left ignores this routinely which is
why i will be exposing leftist fallacies
every friday in 15 minutes or less
exclusively for daily wire members on
our new series debunked
every single week i will take facts and
logic and own the leftist arguments
it's the kind of stuff your friends post
and share all over the internet we will
be debunking all that stuff
and guys whether it is climate change or
universal healthcare i'm going to help
you dismantle those arguments so
if you aren't already a daily wire
member go to dailywire.com
subscribe use code debunked to get 25
off the first episode is dropping soon
head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe today use code debunked for 25
off
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so meanwhile the news media are
fully intent on covering up for the fact
that uh joe biden apparently is putting
kids in cages so here is the funny thing
we talked about this yesterday on the
program a little bit there's an article
in the washington post
it is titled first migrant facility for
children opens under biden and it sounds
fun man it sounds like a summer camp
right according to the washington post
the emergency facility which by the way
is a vestige of the trump administration
that was open for a month in summer 2019
is now being reactivated to hold up to
700 children ages 13 to 17. here's the
thing we need these facilities you know
why we need these facilities because
these are kids who are coming across the
border unaccompanied we can't just
release them to nobody
inside the united states of america we
have to keep them somewhere
and so we put them in the facilities we
have they were not concentration camps
or ghettos or cages
when it was trump and they are not
concentration camps or ghettos or cages
when it is
when it is joe biden and if they were
all those things they were those things
when when
barack obama was president and started
this entire process under flores
okay but according to the washington
post it's amazing
tents tent cities are now soft sided
structures and cages are now migrant
facilities for children
it's all very exciting stuff now members
of the biden administration were in fact
asked about this jen sackey was asked
about this by the only decent reporter
in the white house press corps
apparently
peter ducey so he said you know it's
weird because you guys were ripping on
donald trump and saying kids in cages a
lot i remember because i was there
so why are these not kids in cages
exactly
this is not kids being kept in cages
this is
this is kids this is a facility that was
opened
that's going to follow the same
standards as other hhs facilities it is
not a replication
certainly not though that's that is
never our intention of replicating the
immigration policies of the past
administration but we are in a
circumstance
where we are not going to expel
unaccompanied minors at the border
that would be inhumane so it's not kids
in cages guys
so notice she never explains why it's
not kids in cages
she says that our policy is not the same
as the trump administration's policy
because the trump administration policy
said
we are not going to simply release
people into the interior of the united
states without tracing
where they are right basically there
were two choices under the flora
settlement when you end up with
parents who arrive with kids at the
border right those choices were
either you release both the parents and
the kids or
you release the kids or you release the
parents right you can't have a situation
in which you keep both the parents and
the kids
in facilities together right that was
one of the the problems with the flora
settlement it was an idiotic settlement
uh it was done under the clinton
administration it was ridiculous okay
but
the the bottom line here is that what
she is saying is that the structures are
exactly the same but since our policies
are different it's not kids and cages
anymore
weird because um it's the same kids in
the same cages
but it's not kids in cages anymore and
guess what members of the media are
defending this sort of nonsense you know
again she doesn't actually explain why
it's not kids in cages just says our
policy is different than trump's and
trump is bad the orange man was super
bad so if we do exactly the same thing
as the orange man but our overall policy
is different then that makes it good
post senior political reporter aaron
blake defended the decision
not to call this thing a concentration
camp by the way the paper did refer to
the facilities
during the trump era as quote unquote
concentration camps
so aaron blake said no biden's new
border move isn't just like trump's kids
in cages
blake said the description was justified
because the paper didn't view it as a
good thing
and because the biden administration
doesn't separate children from the
adults accompanying them
it's amazing it's amazing so you've got
the entire media flipping on a dime
and the same exact facilities being used
and they were bad when it was trump and
they are good
when it is biden blake said the first
thing to note is the post coverage
didn't exactly hail this is a good thing
well actually they waited until the
final few paragraphs to talk about why
it was a bad thing otherwise they talked
about how there were soccer fields and
basketball courts
it sounded like fun summer camp man he
called this facility the cadillac of
detention centers
here is the biggest point he added
trump's policy on children at the border
wasn't controversial
merely because it resulted in children
being held at the border which is a
long-standing reality and
is what will happen at this facility it
was controversial because it forced
children to be separated from their
parents given its hardline policy
requiring their parents be held and not
released into the country
so in other words we don't like the
trump policy but the facilities are
exactly the same
but they were cages when it was trump
and they are just
beautiful wonderful trailers when it's
joe biden
these are your objective media amazing
at this stuff so alexander ocasio-cortez
decides to get in on the act and you'll
notice some muted language here from the
irrepressible and incomparably brilliant
democratic congresswoman from twitch she
tweeted out
this is not okay never has been okay
never will be okay
no matter no matter the administration
or party
and uh then she added our immigration
system is built on a carceral framework
it's no accident that challenging how we
approach both these issues are
considered controversial stances they
require reimagining our relationship to
each other
and challenging common assumptions we
take for granted oh like you're not
supposed to cross the border illegally
it's only two months into this
administration and our fraught unjust
immigration system will not transform in
that time
that's why bold reimagination is so
important dhs
shouldn't exist agencies should be
reorganized ice gotta go
ban for-profit detention create climate
refugee status and more
okay so her solution is no more
immigration laws essentially at all
no enforcement mechanism for immigration
but you'll notice one thing that she
didn't do
was head on down to joe biden's cages
for kids
and take a picture dressed in all white
weeping
several hundred yards from the actual
facility you'll notice that she didn't
do that
or call them concentration camps i
wonder what changed
and it's weird how she says there you
know it's only two months in we can't
change things that fast
weird because it seems like it's a
president of her own party shouldn't she
be putting the pressure on
but instead it's like you know it'd be
really nice is if we reimagine utopia by
the way none of these people have a
natural answer as to what you're
supposed to do with unaccompanied kids
who show up at the border
none of them have an answer as to what
you're supposed to do none of them have
an answer as to what you're supposed to
do
when parents and kids show up at the
border and the kids cannot be held so
the kids are released
and the parents have to stay because
they're illegal because they illegally
cross the border
they have no answer to any of these
questions it is all posturing it was
posturing during the trump
administration it remains posturing
today
and they are happy to promulgate any lie
that they can in order
to uphold the ridiculous biden
administration
and by the way it turns out it is indeed
ridiculous you notice something
so joe biden for like a week here did
not go down to texas
remember it was super duper bad when ted
cruz flew off to cancun and i will admit
that was bad optics right
remember when joe biden just basically
went to sleep for like a full week
he just went to sleep and he's like you
know what matlock's on
well it turns out that biden is going to
go to texas on friday now again i don't
like when presidents do this sort of
stuff so i was perfectly fine with him
sleeping in the basement
i was fine with with people doing
whatever they want like i really don't
care
i think that politics if you're looking
to politicians for empathy you are
looking in the wrong place get a dog
politicians don't care about you they
never have cared about you politicians
care
about making sure that their
constituents keep voting for them
and serving their own ambition that is
mainly what politicians do
and i don't feel that our politicians
are are more honest
when they just jet set off to some
location where there is a tragedy and
then hand out water bottles like this
does not make me feel as though they
care more about me
but then again i don't look for empathy
from people i elect i think that's silly
i don't look for empathy for my plumber
for my attorney or for my politicians
but a lot of people do
if you are looking for empathy though
it's kind of weird that joe biden
waited for like a year to go to texas so
now he's going to show up the thing's
over by the way
right like the power is back up things
are getting better and now joe biden is
going to show up
on monday white house press secretary
sackey told reporters that biden is
eager to go to texas
he said well sackey said we're hopeful
the trip can happen as early as this
week apparently they're going to head to
texas
on friday which will heal everything
uh our politics is uh but he's he's
empathetic that's what we know he's not
he may be crappy at policy
but he's empathetic and that means that
he can do exactly the same stuff that
trump did
or he can lie routinely and we all just
give him the space because it's fine and
i'm sure it's all fine
all right coming back later today we'll
have an additional hour of the ben
shapiro show in the meantime
go check out the michael knowles show it
is available right now i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez
the show is edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crams
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021.
joe biden throws migrant kids in cages
dr fauci says to give up
on going to restaurants and a 105 year
old woman beats the virus that shut down
the world check it out on the michael
knowles show